[Applause]
yes i actually
i like reddit i want to get into a
discussion about writing a second but
like
specifically with clubhouse i knew it
was going to bomb because what is the
purpose for the
average person the casual to go on there
like the the coolest person on your
platfor
platform can't be eric weinstein it just
can't be you can't
that's not your he can be on it he can
be a part of it but he can't be the guy
that you go to and you're like that's
what i need to hear every single day
yeah i think it's much more of like a i
don't think it makes sense
for someone in your position that's
already monetizing content
i think what's where it makes it's much
more like eventbrite
than it is like a podcasting a spotify
a youtube type platform yeah it's
like in my line of work as sort of a
architect and designer i used to go to a
lot of design conferences
and you basically go to hear some
thoughts of like industry leaders
it's not a big enough industry to be
televised
and sort of pre-internet it's like where
else do you get these kind of like
thought leaders in this thing that's
really important to me but not
broadly appealing to a mainstream
audience and you have conferences
and there's conferences for engineering
medicine all this kind of stuff
let me let me take back what i was
saying what they did is they um
what is it called when a company uh
creates an evaluation they they
created a valid evaluation for the
company that was far too high
yeah and like we work like we work right
so they we work themselves
if clubhouse was just like this young
cool thing
and let itself evolve into basically a
conference app
hey here's going to be a conference
about architecture here's a conference
about design
here's a conference about ufos here's a
conference about math etc
you know um i liked what tim dillon was
doing on there yeah right he would he
would have like sarcastic conversation
can women own bitcoin
like that'd be great awesome funny
you're satirizing
what everybody else is really talking
about it great idea if they did that
they literally came out and said this is
replacing instagram this is replacing
twitter
this is replacing facebook this is the
new thing everything else will get shut
down this is the only way you make money
and when you do that you set yourself up
for failure because you don't even know
the identity of the app yet right
like i looked at it for a second i was
like hot chicks can't be on here
and they can't show off and they're not
going to talk it's not going to work
the the technology is kind of impressive
although it's not their technology they
use sort of a standard off-the-shelf
piece of
tech from what i understand that kind of
mixes the voices and stuff
it works really well i think the thing
that they hit on is the same thing
that you've realized for a long time
with podcasts is that there's a lot more
available
inventory of partial attention than
there is full attention
like how much that down
break that down okay i don't watch that
many shows
but i listen to a lot of audio content
because i have a lot of time where
i'm working out or uh
driving driving or building something
or so you have a lot more
passive time than you do like active
attention time
when i was doing mtv shows i called them
uh
laundry day shows right mtv didn't like
that
but i knew what the people were doing
when they were watching guy code
they wanted to show that they could pop
in at any time in the episode it could
be 12 minutes in it could be six minutes
in it could be 23 minutes in
and they would be fine right because
there was no beginning there was no
middle there was no end
and they could fold their laundry pop in
for a joke come back out continue
folding their laundry
everything was fine game of thrones we
are locked in right you and i can handle
one of those or two of those right you
can't watch four hours of that in a day
i mean
you do but then that's it right you
can't do for those shows a week where
you're just
locked in impossible right so there's a
lot more of this kind of snacking
partial attention time with that yes so
i think that's what's really interested
and and then the ability to sort of
connect it with live like i think the
future of clubhouse one
everyone else is creating a competitor
for it so the question is whether it can
be in its own platform or just a feature
in every platform yes kind of shared
audio experience
yeah but i think it's a really great
idea for like kind of like ufc fight
companion
kind of super bowl parties and stuff
like that where you can create a custom
one with your friends across the country
and like all be on like one sort of
audio channel like and it's
pretty seamlessly and pretty easy to use
that's what i thought it could be
uh used as like you know how like a
twitch there are people who will stream
something and then react to it while
it's being screamed
and i was like okay if they're if they
can do this for a ufc fight and then
like what joe did with the fight
companion right
now you have a platform where you can at
least listen to your favorite
commentators or even your favorite
fighters talk about the fight as it's
going on
while you're watching it at home right i
thought that was great if they could
integrate that in any way even if they
don't integrate it even they get the
timing synced
where it's happening live i think you're
good that would be great with sports
and eventually these sports channels
will offer deals to those people that
have really popular clubhouse channels
and yada yada it doesn't matter
that could be what it is but in its
current form i was like no this can't be
it dude
yeah and the evangelizing you saw for it
was
is i saw a lot of people that hadn't
really built up big audiences on other
channels
and they go over to clubhouse and
they're early adopters yeah and they
suddenly get a hundred thousand
followers in one week and then of course
they're incentivized to say this is the
truth this is the best thing ever
because i
got a little bit of a leader and it must
be a good app because they're
recognizing how great i am
yeah well i mean the other apps they
have great taste exactly
yeah yeah it's like i'm appreciated here
this is awesome yeah like comedians
start like uh
posting on tick tock and then like
they'd get these huge followings on tick
tock
and uh the videos do crazy numbers and
then like
this is the app this is the truth etc
it's like well is tic toc getting people
to the show
yeah are those numbers real yeah well
i went on tik tok i did like a one video
and it did
did big numbers i'm like oh tick tock's
pretty cool then i did five more videos
and they got [ __ ] i was like
stupid [ __ ] platform and you know
what it is yeah you get the initial bump
they know what they're doing yeah they
see it's your first time they will
they've learned from everyone
else yes and so they kind of know that
oh if we distribute
if we distribute virality kind of
randomly and maybe kind of pump up the
numbers
we'll encourage people and they'll keep
chasing
it feels good when you do something that
wasn't hard
and it gets seen by hundreds of
thousands if not millions of people you
know
the was it hard part is so important
and then it's like if that happens once
early in the first month of using it
you're gonna kind of like come back oh
maybe yeah yeah we'll try that yeah
yeah yeah that's the weird thing about
like our business though
is that we need the numbers to equate to
something else yeah you know like we
need for example if if there's
advertising being sold
on those numbers on tick tock and then
you're seeing a paycheck based on that
you're like i don't care if you fake it
or not you're gonna have to pay me yeah
you know and like for me it's like if
people are coming out of the shows
because it's a tick tock i'm like
great whatever those numbers are awesome
but if you give me a million and then
we don't sell any tickets off it that's
a zero for me and by the way thank god
we protected our national security and
got rid of tick tock yes
i'm down to get rid of it still i know
because we don't use it exactly
you try to get rid of instagram
you get rid of youtube or instagram we
got a [ __ ] problem
yes we're also very self-serving in that
way 100 that's like yeah
i don't really use that one it seems
like a younger people are doing it it
could be an eventual
existential threat to my media career oh
that's what oh yeah let's ban it that's
what you said i was just like this is
for pedophiles
why would you let a pedophile
you